debería crear una cuenta de fideicomiso para cada recién nacido
de hasta USD 60 000,
calculada según la riqueza de la familia en la cual nacieron.
Hablo de un fondo.
Un capital inicial personal, un fondo establecido públicamente para bebés,
a lo que mi colega William Darity en la Universidad Duke y yo
hemos llamado "bonos para bebés",
un término acuñado por un historiador ya fallecido de la Universidad de Columbia,
Manning Marable.
La razón por la que debemos crear estos fondos es simple.
La riqueza es el indicador fundamental de seguridad económica y bienestar.
Proporciona libertad financiera, seguridad económica para tomar riesgos
y protección contra las pérdidas.
Sin capital, la desigualdad se mantiene.
Usamos palabras como elección o libertad para describir los beneficios del mercado,
pero es la riqueza la que nos da elección, libertad y opcionalidad.
Las familias más ricas pueden pagar una escuela privada de elite
y una educación universitaria,
acceder a capitales para empezar un negocio,
financiar tratamientos médicos caros,
residir en vecindarios con mejor infraestructura,
ejercer influencia política a través de la financiación de campañas,
conseguir una mejor asesoría legal
si deben enfrentarse con un sistema de justicia criminal caro,
dejar una herencia
y resistir las dificultades financieras producidas por diferentes crisis.
Básicamente, cuando se trata de seguridad económica,
la riqueza está tanto al principio como al final.
Enmarcaré esta conversación en el contexto de los EE. UU.,
pero está discusión se aplica virtualmente a cualquier país
que enfrente una desigualdad creciente.
En EE. UU., el 10 % de los hogares
poseen alrededor del 80 % de la riqueza nacional
mientras que el 60 % de la base solo posee un 1 %.
Pero en cuanto a la riqueza,
la raza es aún un predictor más fuerte que la clase misma.
Los negros y los latinos constituyen el 30 %
de la población de EE.UU.,
pero, colectivamente, poseen un 7 % de la riqueza nacional.
La encuesta de 2016 sobre la financiación al consumo
indica que la típica familia negra tiene una riqueza de unos USD 17 000,
y eso incluye el capital de vivienda,
mientras que la típica familia blanca tiene unos USD 170 000.
Esto indica una gran brecha racial de riqueza
donde el típico hogar negro posee unos 10 centavos por cada dólar
que posee la típica familia blanca.
Pero independientemente de la raza,
el mercado mismo ha sido inadecuado para encargarse de estas desigualdades.
La desigualdad aumenta incluso en épocas de expansión económica.
Durante los últimos 45 años
la disparidad en la riqueza ha aumentado drásticamente
y, en esencia, toda la ganancia económica del aumento de la productividad en EE. UU.
ha ido a la elite o a la clase media alta.
Sin embargo, muchos de los planteamientos sobre la disparidad económica
se centran en las malas elecciones
de los negros, latinos y los prestatarios pobres.
Esta perspectiva está equivocada.
El énfasis direccional está equivocado.
Es más probable que la magra circunstancia económica,
y no las malas decisiones o los conocimientos deficientes,
limiten las elecciones en sí mismas y dejen a la gente la única opción
de volcarse a una finanza predatoria.
En esencia, la educación no es el antídoto mágico
contra las enormes desigualdades heredadas
que resultan de las leyes, las medidas y los acuerdos económicos.
Esto no disminuye el valor de la educación.
De hecho, soy profesor universitario.
La educación tiene un valor intrínseco claro,
junto con la responsabilidad pública
de exponer a cada uno a una educación de alta calidad,
desde la escuela primaria hasta la universidad.
Pero la educación no es una panacea.
De hecho, las familias negras con un jefe de familia graduado en la universidad
tienen típicamente menos riqueza
que las familias blancas con un jefe de familia que no terminó la secundaria.
Quizá exageramos el papel funcional de la educación
en detrimento de entender el papel funcional de la riqueza.
Básicamente, la riqueza engendra más riqueza.
Por eso abogamos por un fondo para bebés.
Un derecho de nacimiento económico para todos.
Estas cuentas se mantendrían en un fondo público
para usarlas como una base para una vida económicamente segura.
El concepto de derechos económicos no es nuevo ni radical.
En 1944, el presidente Franklin Roosevelt
introdujo la idea de una Carta de derechos económicos.
Roosevelt demandaba seguridad física,
seguridad económica, seguridad social y seguridad moral.
Desafortunadamente, desde la administración Nixon,
la opinión política sobre la movilidad social
cambió radicalmente desde los mandatos de gobierno para la seguridad económica
hasta una perspectiva neoliberal
en la cual se considera al mercado como la solución a todos nuestros problemas
económicos o de otro tipo.
Como resultado, el peso de la movilidad social ha pasado al individuo.
La narrativa generalizada es que, aunque nuestra suerte en la vida sea mediocre,
con perseverancia, esfuerzo y las virtudes del mercado libre
podemos cambiar de la pobreza a la riqueza.
Por supuesto, la otra cara de la moneda es que las virtudes del mercado
sancionarán asimismo a los que no son astutos,
a los que les falta motivación o los que simplemente son perezosos.
Es decir, el pobre que lo merezca recibirá su recompensa justa.
Lo que evidentemente falta en esta narrativa
es el papel del poder y del capital,
y cómo ese poder y ese capital
pueden usarse para alterar las reglas y la estructura
de las transacciones y los mercados.
El poder y el capital se autorefuerzan.
Y sin la intervención del gobierno,
generan un ciclo repetitivo de estratificación y desigualdad.
El capital financiero proporcionado por el fondo para bebés
está destinado a brindar una vía más igualitaria y auténtica
hacia la seguridad económica,
independiente de la posición financiera de la familia
en la que nacen los individuos.
El programa complementaría los derechos económicos a las pensiones de jubilación
y proveería un programa de seguridad social más amplio,
designado a proporcionar capital financiero desde la cuna hasta la tumba.
Imaginamos dotar a los recién nacidos de EE. UU. con una cuenta de unos USD 25 000
que aumente en forma gradual hasta los USD 60 000
para los bebés nacidos en las familias más pobres.
Los bebés nacidos en las familias más ricas
también estarían incluidos en el contrato social,
pero recibirían una cuenta más simbólica de unos USD 500.
Las cuentas se administrarían federalmente
y crecerían con una tasa de interés anual garantizada
de un 2 % anual, para reducir el costo de la inflación;
el chico la usaría al llegar a la mayoría de edad
para alguna actividad que mejore su posición,
como financiar una educación sin deudas,
un depósito para comprar una casa
o un capital inicial para empezar un negocio.
Con unos cuatro millones de bebés que nacen cada año en EE. UU.
si el promedio de la dotación de un fondo para bebés se establece en USD 25 000
el programa costaría aproximadamente unos USD 100 000 millones por año.
Esto constituiría
solo un 1 % de los gastos federales actuales
y sería mucho menos que los más de USD 500 000 millones
que ya gasta el gobierno federal
en la promoción de recursos a través de créditos impositivos y subsidios.
La cuestión no es la cantidad que se asigna,
sino a quién se distribuye.
Actualmente, el 1 % superior de los hogares,
los que ganan por encima de USD 100 millones,
reciben solo alrededor de un tercio de toda esta asignación,
mientras que el 60 % inferior solo recibe el 5 %.
Si el presupuesto federal
fuera asignado de forma más progresiva,
la política federal podría ser transformadora para los estadounidenses.
Esta es una obra en proceso.
Obviamente hay muchos detalles que resolver,
pero es una propuesta de una política basada en los roles funcionales
y en las ventajas de la riqueza heredada
que nos alejan de reforzar la situación actual
de explicaciones conductuales sobre la desigualdad
hacia soluciones más estructurales.
Nuestra política de impuestos actual privilegia la riqueza existente
en vez de establecer que la riqueza nueva es una elección.
La magnitud de la enorme desigualdad no es tanto un problema de políticas
como un problema económico.
Es hora de ir más allá de las narrativas falsas
que atribuyen la desigualdad a las deficiencias personales individuales
mientras se ignoran totalmente las ventajas de la riqueza.
En cambio, la provisión pública de un fondo para bebés
podría ayudar mucho a eliminar
el traspaso de las ventajas o desventajas económicas a través de las generaciones
y establecer una economía más moral y decente
que proporcione bienes, seguridad económica
y movilidad social para todos los ciudadanos,
sin importar la raza
o la posición familiar en la que nacen.
Muchas gracias.
(Aplausos)
Chris Anderson: Darrick.
Esta es una idea que gusta mucho.
Hay algo en ella que me preocupa,
y es que, en este momento, los fondos infantiles tienen una mala reputación.
Sabes, son el tipo de esos carteles irritantes sobre los niños
por como el dinero... digamos, que quitan la motivación.
Así que estos fondos son diferentes.
Entonces, ¿cómo le muestras a la gente que esta propuesta no hará eso?
Darrick Hamilton: Si sabes que tienes recursos limitados
o que enfrentarás discriminación,
hay una narrativa que, bueno,
los beneficios económicos de invertir en mí
son menores que los de otro,
así que bien podría disfrutar de mi ocio.
Por supuesto, también hay otra narrativa,
así que no quedaríamos atrapados en eso,
sabes, alguien que es pobre y enfrentará la discriminación,
también podrían dedicarse a construir un currículo;
el viejo adagio: "Debo ser el doble de bueno que los demás".
Pero al decirlo, nunca preguntamos cuál es el costo,
y hay costos de salud asociados con eso.
No respondí tu pregunta, pero volviendo a ella,
si sabes que recibirás una transferencia más tarde en la vida,
eso solo aumenta tu incentivo para invertir en ti mismo
para poder usar mejor esos fondos.
CA: Les estás dando a la gente posibilidades de vida
que actualmente no pueden imaginar que tengan.
Y, por tanto, la motivación para hacerlo.
Podría hablar horas contigo sobre esto.
Me complace mucho que trabajes en esto.
Gracias.
(Aplausos)